you are Pretty in Pink I love the
eyeshadow love the dress and I love your
uh plus one tonight he's matching with
his hair you guys are having a cute date
night out how are things going things
are going great we both have the hair
it's in there somewhere like a YouTube
too I did not
I just said come on in I just said I was
like oh he's matching you with the hair
and she goes on me too and I had no I
didn't even yeah you're rocking the pink
tonight it's it's date night out how
much fun are you two having just
enjoying each other and your Journeys
together I I just got engaged I love
love so I'm like I always bring it back
to that I think you know there's been so
many things that have happened since
we've you know started dating whether it
was dancing with the stars or his own
music Journey and it's been really nice
to kind of watch each other and be there
to support each other through all these
crazy times and you know get to go to
things like this together and dress up
it's always very fun are you gonna head
out on the road for the Dancing with the
Stars tour and See Her Shine yeah yeah
for sure I'll definitely be at some
UB front row when she is hosting the
Kids Choice Awards coming up
congrats MGK everyone's doing so well
it's so great to see like friends like
that I mean you guys know each other
very well how proud are you he's he's up
for his album which is amazing yeah I
know I'm I'm super hyped for him
I've known Kells for a long time I'm
super stoked for him he deserves it I
can't wait to see your hosting it's a
it's hosting is a lot of work as you
know what how are you prepping well I'm
very lucky I have I think the best
co-host I could ask for someone who's so
comfortable with hosting and it's just
so naturally talented and gifted when it
comes to you know making other feel
comfortable he's made it really easy for
me so far
foreign